welcome back we're now in problem number
11. let's see at the top there right
z
w
y
x
and they say the sequence above may be
changed in either of two ways either two
adjacent letters may be interchanged or
the entire sequence may be reversed
either like i could switch like w and y
or i could just switch the order
what is the least number of changes
needed to put the numbers into
alphabetical order from left to right
alphabetical order from left to right so
what is alphabetical order from doctor
let's know our goal
because my i have it's been a while
since i've sung my alphabet so
it's w
x
y
z this is our goal
right so let's see what we can do
w
x y z so we need to get w at the
opposite end from let's see if i could i
could switch
these two
and i would get z
w
x y
no no no no no i want to get the w at
the opposite end of
so we could switch
oh we what we want to do is switch w and
y right and we will get z
y w x then you can switch
x and w you get z
y x w and then the other option we can
do is just reverse and then we can
reverse
and when we reverse it we get w x
y
z
and that's our goal so that took us
that took us it took us one step
two steps
three steps
so that's choice b i'm not sure if
that's the right answer let's see if i
can do it in two steps
let's see if i reversed it well
reversing doesn't really help you
the bottom line is you have to
before you reverse
w x y z i mean to move the z all the way
over to the other end no you want to
just reverse
if you reverse this and you reverse this
and you switch i think that's the
fastest possible way i can
because you you need no matter what you
do no matter what you do you have to
move the w
two steps away from the z you have to do
that right
because the w is on the opposite end
from the z so you have to move the w
twice that's going to take you at least
two steps and then you gotta switch
switch the
switch the order that's the third step
the other option and it'll be even it'd
be even worse if you didn't switch the
order and you had to you wanted to move
the z
the other options you could flip the z
and the w and you would get
you would get
w z
y x
and then you could switch
you could switch now that's going to
take you you could switch the x and the
y and you'd get w
z
x y
now that's gonna take you three or four
steps so i'm pretty sure we got the
right answer write me write me a little
note if i didn't
next problem
the bottom line with that one you have
to realize you have to switch move the w
at least three away from the z
and then you gotta reverse it so it's
gonna take you at least three steps
problem number twelve i hope i'm right
on that one
how many cubical blocks each with edges
of length four centimeters are needed to
fill a rectangular box that has inside
dimensions
so
each of my initial blocks looks like you
know i'll draw my cube as best as i can
our four by four by 4.
and that is how many cubic centimeters
these are centimeters right so 16 times
equals 64 centimeters cubed or 64 cubic
centimeters
and we want to fill
a box that has inside dimensions
so we want to fill a box that has inside
dimensions this is my big box
let's see 20 by 24
by
32.
so there's a couple of ways you could do
this you could you could just measure
you don't even have to do this first
step i did you could just say well how
many of these small boxes are going to
fit in this direction how many are in
this direction and how many in this
direction and then multiply and that's
actually the fast way to do it so you
could say if you said instead of drawing
it that way you could let me redraw that
big box
but instead of giving it in centimeters
let me give it in how many of these
boxes are going to go in this direction
so it's going to be
these are four centers each and the base
is 20 so it's going to be 20 divided by
4. it's going to be 5 in this direction
it's going to be 6 in this direction 24
divided by 4 it's going to be 8 in this
direction so then you can just multiply
5 times 6
is 30 times 8 is 240 of the boxes
the other way to do it is you could have
multiplied 20 times 24 times 32 you
could have said this equals 20 times 24
times 32
and then divided by
64. that would have been the other way
to do doing it and it would just require
more math
and hopefully that comes out to the same
thing as 240. and that's choice d
if you ever find yourself on the sat
doing something that's really hairy or
taking a lot of time you're not
necessarily doing it wrong but there's
probably a faster way to do it because
they want you to be able to do these
questions in like less than 30 seconds
i think you have time to do them a
little over a minute
13. if zero is less than n
zero is less than n which is less than
one
which of the following gives the correct
ordering of
square root of n
n
and n squared
you want the easiest thing to do when
they give you a problem like this is
just try out a number try out a number
like well do you want a good number is
here because we have to take the square
root of it let's take n equal 1 4
because it's easy to take the square
root of 1 4. so if n is equal to 1 4
then what are these values square root
of n is equal to one half
right it actually equals plus or minus
one-half but they probably mean the
positive one-half
n is 1 4
right and what's n squared
n squared is 1 over 16
116. i'm assuming that they mean the
positive square root when they when they
write it like that so if what's what's
the order of these well the the smallest
they want to do it right from smallest
to biggest so the smallest is n squared
then the next biggest is
square root of n
no no sorry then the next one is n and
then the next one is square root of n
and that's choice
that is choice
e
and another way to think about it is
when you have a fraction and essentially
that's what they're saying you have a
fraction less than one or you have a
decimal point right
it becomes bigger when you take the
square root and it becomes smaller when
you square it
that's the realization that you know so
the the squaring is going to be smaller
than the number which is smaller than
the square root
that's kind of the the underlying theme
when a number is between zero and one
but if you didn't want to think too
abstractly about it just try out a
number that works
see next problem
problem number 14.
problem number 14. okay so this is going
to involve some drawing
let me see if i can draw this pretty
fast
that's my y-axis that's my x-axis
then there's a bunch of lines there's a
b c okay so they're all at they all
intersect at
at three and then
these one
one
two
three
four
five
and six
and let me draw out all the all the
lines so the first line goes something
like this it goes from there
then all the other ones i see the next
one goes to three
next one goes to three
next one goes to four
next one goes to five they all go to y
equals three
the last one goes to six
three okay
and they're saying in the figure above
what is the median of the slopes of all
of those lines o a o b o c right this
this they say this is
they write a
b
c
d
e
what is the median so this isn't the
average median is easier median is just
what's the middle slope right so we
could say well this
let me switch colors line a has the
highest slope line b is a little bit
lower line c is a little bit lower the
slope is getting a little bit
lower as we go out right and you can
figure that out by rise over run the
rise is the same in every case and the
run just gets bigger and bigger right
the change in x gets bigger and bigger
so this has the highest slope
this has the lowest slope and this has
the middle slope see
pretty easy
oh the median of the slope so they want
you to figure it out so what is the
slope of 3 of this one so it's change in
change in y
so change in y is 3
over change in x
which is 4 which is 4. sorry so it's
three-fourths so that's choice c
the if you got this wrong maybe by
accident you took the the mean or the
average which would probably take wasted
a lot of time as well
i'll see you in the next video